para ti tiene una hermosa planta la
planta comenzó a retoñar dos días antes
de que patti la comprara y la tuvo por
98 días antes de que muriera la altura
máxima de la planta fue de 30
centímetros digamos que hdt denota la
altura de la planta de patín h medida en
centímetros que son los días que pasaron
a partir de que ella compró la planta
cual tipo de número es más apropiado
para el dominio de la función
tenemos enteros o reales y define el
intervalo del dominio bueno tenemos que
recordar que el dominio de una función
es el conjunto de todos los valores de
entrada válidos para los que la función
a está definida
aquí las entradas están definidas por
esta t minúscula que representa los días
si pongo como entrada el número de días
en la función h
no será como salida la altura de la
planta
pensemos en ello podemos pensar en
términos de 0 días un día dos días y
quizá estén tentados de elegir los
enteros como dominio pero por qué no
pensar en un día y medio o tres puntos
75 días así que no veo por qué t no
puede ser un subconjunto de los números
reales pensando en el dia 97.9 999 así
que el dominio son números reales y cuál
va a ser el intervalo del dominio que
estará definida desde dos días antes de
que la planta fuera comprada por lo que
te va desde -2 hasta 98 días y se
incluye el -2 y el 98 así que aquí
elegimos los corchetes porque estoy
incluyendo al menos 2 el valor mínimo
del rango si el rango fuera mayor pero
no igual a menos 2 usaría los paréntesis
pero como t si puede ser igual a menos 2
voy a usar el corchete
un máximo del rango es 98 y como podemos
incluir el 98
vamos a usar los corchetes que es
miembro de los números reales tal que te
puede ser mayor o igual a menos 2 y
menor o igual a 98